I was at a Blake Masters fundraiser in  Miami at Peter thiel's house and he gave  a quick speech and I was admittedly like  I was like wait Peter Thiel is like a  Silicon Valley guy Facebook like come on  I'm not and his his speech which you  know early PayPal was great current  PayPal sucks early PayPal was amazing  yeah uh and his speech blew me away  three minutes and I was like ooh he's a  good guy now and I think we've seen that  with Elon Musk with you know Joe Rogan  like these guys they're kind of getting  more and more emboldened with Tim Poole  um I I think uh he said we have about  three years left to save America from a  communist takeover Peterson  I mean he has a very last year he has it  too he has a very interesting career  especially what happened with BuzzFeed  especially him being ousted by them and  then kind of getting retribution through  Hogan him coming out and supporting  Donald Trump especially during the RNC  was pretty ballsy too but